Not even the Grim Reaper himself starving to get his hands on my warrior's soul...
...can keep me from hearing the battle cries of the warrior...
...in the WWE Universe to experience WWE 2K14.
Pay attention!
Never before so many superstars stepped up to challenge our throne.
And if you pre-order WWE 2K14, you've just engaged the battle as the Ultimate Warrior.
Yeah!
That power!
This intensity!
Your belief!
Our destiny!
All of it together created the one and only Ultimate Warrior.
All of us the freaks, we did it our time but we'll live forever
Hold this, boss.
Pre-order WWE 2K14 today and battle the one and only Ultimate Warrior.
Become immortal.
WWE 2K14, pre-order now!